الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا قمتم برصد
العشرات من الاخبار المضلله ما هي ابرز
هذه السرديات حول الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
نعم قمنا برصد 115 حاله من الاخبار
المضلله منذ بدايه الحرب وقد نشرنا دراسه
تتناول مختلف انواع هذه الاخبار الكاذبه
وكذلك اساليب وتقنيات الترويج لها ومن ثم
قمنا
بمحاوله رصد المواقع التي نشرت عليها هذه
المعلومات قمنا بفحص الفيديوهات وصور
الاكثر تداول على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
جمال ما هي التقنيات التي يلجا اليها
المروجون لهذه الاكاذيب على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
بدايه ساتحدث عن سرديات او الروايات بعض
الروايات التي سواء كانت تخدم الجانب
الاوكراني او الروسي قمنا مثلا بالتحقق من
22 محتوى مضلل تم تقديمها على انها ادله
تثبت بان الرئيس
الجيش الاوكراني
يطغى عليه الايديولوجيه النازيه تسيطر على
الجيش الاوكراني ذلك خاصه وان الرئيس
الروسي استعمل يعني كدريعه موضوع اجتثاث
النازيه في اوكرانيا لغزوه لهذه البلاد
فمثلا هناك فيديو
سيظهر على الشاشه ويظهر على الشاشه يتهم
من خلاله الرئيس الاوكراني انه الف كتابا
يحمل نفس عنوان كتاب
ولكن عندما تحققنا من هذا الفيديو
تبين انه لا اساس له من الصحه كذلك فيه
العديد من الفيديوهات الكاذبه التي تتهم
الجانب الاوكراني بانه يقوم بفبركه
فيديوهات تمثيليه لجلب تعاطف الغرب فمثلا
هنا
يتهم جندي
يزعم انه جندي اوكراني
احتياط قام بتصوير فيديو تمثيلي وبالطبع
تاكدنا من ذلك وهو غير صحيح في الجانب
الاوكراني هناك نسبه قليله من الاخبار
الكاذبه يعني لما نقارنها مع السرديه
الروسيه لكن معظمها تقوم باتهام الرئيس
الروسي بانه يستخدم ممثلين كوميديا ممثلين
مسرح عندما يقوم بتنقلاته لانه يخشع عن
نفسه وانه مصاب ببارانويا لكن عندما تح
هؤلاء الاشخاص تبين ان الموضوع خاطئ وان
الخبر غير صحيح طيب جمال التقنيات
[موسيقى]
في طريقه عفوا
طبعا تحققنا من هذا الفيديو
يمكن ان نرى ان يعني على الفيديو انه يوجد
شعار فوكس قناه تلفزيون الامريكيه فوكس
بكل بساطه اتصلنا بقناه وكذلك اتصلنا
بوكاله الاعلانات التي تدير هذه الشاشه
لكن قالت لنا ان لا علاقه لها بهذه بهذه
بهذا الفيديو وكذلك الوكاله قانت انها
ليست وراء هذه الاعلان وحتى انه لم يتم
بثه على الاطلاق طيب جمال يعني هذه الصور
من مدينه نيويورك
ما هي المواقع والحسابات التي تنشر عليها
هذه الاشاعات فيما يتعلق بالحسابات في
المرحله الاولى يتم نشر هذه
المعلومات الكاذبه باللغه
الروسيه على مجموعات تيليجرام ثم يتم
نسخها باللغتين الانجليزيه والفرنسيه في
محاوله لاعطاء صدى لهذه المحتويات بعد ذلك
تقوم بوسائل الاعلام التابعه داعمه بنشر
هذه الاخبار
شكرا جزيلا لك الزميل جمال بلعياش على هذه
التفاصيل